all right we're gonna go to georgia uh
it looks like we got sarah on the line
sarah how are you
i'm good guys i love you oh we're
focused and not finished what's on your
mind today
well we we got a little crisis going on
so hopefully you guys can help um
what happened my husband and i
we are military so we're finally home
and we brought a home
va loan of course and we didn't know
about you guys so
don't bite my head off we didn't know
about you guys until
january so we bought the house in
december okay
so we started the baby steps we're doing
a remedy plus we're doing financial
peace university so we're doing
everything and we're in baby step
two okay however the crisis
is the house we bought the basement
flooded
and it's been flooding
in february beginning in february
and we've had three plumbers come in and
they're telling us
we need to well one they're saying that
the sellers probably
did the work themselves and did not do
it correctly all three of them are
saying that
and also they're um telling us the work
is gonna cost about
between ten to fifteen thousand dollars
to get it sick
okay so hold on a second so it's 10 to
15 to get it fixed
have you reached out to your realtor yes
we did and she looked at it and saw
there's a bathroom that
was remodeled and saw there was no
permanent food
and then got us in contact with a lawyer
trying to
figure out what to do with the yesterday
and they're saying that they're gonna
write a letter to the sellers hoping
that they would cover
the damage but if they don't it will
take one year
because there's a
you know a delayed important all the
court things yeah let me ask you this
did you all get a home inspection done
yes he did and this was not on it at all
like the realtor also double checked
okay well
here here sarah first of all i want to
thank you and your husband for their
your service
in the military i'm grateful for you and
i like that you have been
hyper proactive uh everything that i've
asked you you've got an answer for
you've been moving down the path
now the main thing is we got to get this
fixed right
right so what's true all's income
we bring him uh eight thousand dollars a
month
okay it came up and what else do you owe
on outside of this home
okay um i have it right here my
loan rental plug um i have
a government credit card 2400
in my car which is 36 000.
i'm sorry you faded out on me on that
how much is this car
36 okay you didn't fade out i was just
making you say it one more time
what's the payment on this thing um
eight hundred dollars how much is the
payment on your mortgage
about 15
45. do you see a problem there sarah
yeah all right so guess what one of the
first things you all can do to help you
with this
finding this money to fix this basement
is this vehicle what kind of car
is it it's a tell you that
okay all right i want you to go out
there and tell it to ride
all right ride on off into the sunset
it's time to sell this thing
it's time to kick it to the curb you're
going to free up 800
a month in your budget right and so
this is that mindset listen to me i love
that you guys are in ramsey plus
and i want to get your thoughts on this
but i love that y'all in ramsey plus i
love that you know your numbers
you're proactive and what i would say is
right now you're on the cusp of being
able to make a change
but one of the sacrifices i would make
is getting this vehicle sold
go to kellybluebook.com find out the
value call up the lender get a 30 day
payoff so you know what it would take to
get it out of your life
you guys go get a thousand or two
thousand dollar car you're gonna free up
800
to fix this water problem yeah sarah i'm
curious do you have any uh savings right
now
uh we have um
about 5 000. about 5 000 in savings
okay yeah they told us about the fed
okay
um here's my suggestion from i agree
with hogan
we got to get that car but right now we
we need to really figure out this whole
flooding thing because that can cause
some more issues
and so why are you going through the
process with your attorney i would reach
out to maybe
one more uh one more plumber one more
person to see what they can do
and try and figure out will someone work
with you
okay while you're talking to your
attorney why are you're looking to get
out of this
car uh to create some free some extra
income there
but even if you sell your car today it's
only ex
it's an extra eight hundred dollars but
right now um which you need to get rid
of that car
so you can get on your journey but how
do we get this flooding fixed
so that way we don't have mildew issues
we have to worry about a lot of a lot of
other issues so i would you got five
thousand
sit on that five thousand and moving
forward i want you to pause paying your
debt
okay i want you to pause paying your
debt i want you to put that on top of
this money
that's going to all go towards fixing
this water
leak all right because this is a this is
a true emergency
that could impact the family and cause
more issues
you mean paul's paying extra yeah paul's
paying extra on the day i want you to
pause i don't want you pause paying your
bills no
uh but i want you to pause paying extra
so pause babysit number two
but then figure out okay talk to winner
extra person and then ask all three of
them hey listen we got seven thousand
dollars
what can we do to uh fix this issue
we can give you seven thousand dollars
cash right now can y'all come down
can you help us what can we do but do
what hogan says
you guys a kid i mean 800 car note that
is uh 50 more than 50
of your mortgage payments that is
ridiculous
but you're right ao the water's got to
get drained out yeah we got to turn off
the water down there or
fix like you said get seven thousand
dollars worth of it done
the good thing is is you all are making
8 000 a month yeah so
you know you all paying the mortgage
payment make the minimum payment on the
credit card
paying that car note until you can get
that thing sold
you guys could can get this done in
phases absolutely uh
and get it fixed i agree uh but yes
definitely pursue the legal options on
this because this is uh this is an issue
and uh this is a major dollar repair
that you all are dealing with
uh but don't lose hope uh this is the
thing one of those things that life
happened ao is just talking about his
car issues
and i've walked through some issues and
it's real easy to get so frustrated and
irritated that you lose hope
and you don't want to do that and so
sarah i'm glad you reached out you're
talking about this is on your mind uh
believe me
you know you you can end up giving other
people hope by being honest enough and
open enough to talk about your own
situation
uh thank you and i'm glad that you're
plugged into ramsey plus it means you're
connected and getting the right
information now it's the the execution
of of the
the process and trying to get this thing
resolved i agree
and that's you know it's irritating man
i'll tell you when you deal with a
setback
when you are moving forward and trying
to go down the path to the next
destination
and deal with life throwing you a curve
it's frustrating it's so
frustrating hogan and i understand her
pain man
because i'm literally going through it
right now like i didn't ask for this i
didn't want this
but when you that's this is why you got
to get out of debt
have a fully funded emergency fund for
when stuff like this happens
it sucks but you are prepared yeah for
it that's right
and people are dealing with this in all
phases whether it's in your apartment
whether it's in your home
car repair yes i mean it's always
something popping up
but you know here's what i've learned
when you have an emergency fund
an emergency fee and turns an in an
emergency into just an inconvenience yes
where you just go like this oh well i
mean all right this is what i got to do
this is what i got to do right
i'm going to deal with this but if you
don't have an emergency fund it turns it
into
oh my goodness like where do i turn what
do i do and then you get panicked
then you get desperate and then that's
when stupid can creep in
right so again get to emergency fund be
clear on what it is you're doing
but be certain of what you're not gonna
do right this is the ramsey show